twitter a décidé de marquer d'un libellé
les comptes des médias affiliés à un
état et de réduire leur portée est ce le
cas pour tous les médias et bien la
réponse est non si rt ou cctv se voit
infliger cette notification d'autres
médias financiers par des états
étrangers comme france 24 où la bbc
échappe
et c'est loin d'être la première fois
qu'il critique off
et ça continue ah oui pas s'arrêter en
si bon chemin
vu que désormais ce sont les réseaux
sociaux qui décide de qui est
journaliste et qui ne l'est pas autant
continuer depuis le 6 août
twitter a décidé d'ajouter un petit
libellé sous les comptes de certains
médias pour je cite fournir aux
internautes davantage de contexte sur
ses comptes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en vérité pas
grand chose le but qu'on devine derrière
cet étiquetage et politique désormais
lorsque vous vous rendrez sur le compte
twitter de rt france vous verrez ça
[Musique]
officiellement twitter se dédouane de
toute stigmatisation l'art actuel libéré
s'affiche sur les comptes twitter
conserver des cinq pays membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies chine etats unis france
royaume uni et russie
dans les faits c'est faux ni france24 ni
la bbc nil américaine npr national
public radio ne voient leur compte
porter de signes distinctifs seuls ceux
liés à la chine et la russie sont
concernés en gros les méchants du
conseil de sécurité quoi twitter évoque
les comptes gouvernementaux fortement
engagé en matière de géopolitique et de
diplomatie
c'est sûr que la france ou le royaume
uni ne sont pas du tout engagé en
matière de géopolitique ou de diplomatie
aujourd'hui pour vous dire d'abord
la solidarité l'amitié du peuple
français et le peuple libanais je ne
négocierai aucun délai avec l'union
européenne
pas du tout concernant médias
indépendants les médias liés un métal
qui distrait qu'avant la couverture de
l'actualité à des fins politiques ah
parce que ce que fait twitter en
stigmatisant un média ça n'a rien de
politique
nous pensons que les gens ont le droit
de savoir quand le compte d'un média est
inquiet directement ou indirectement un
acteur étatique
nous pensons que vous faites dans la
stigmatisation la plus primaire pierre
twitter vous avons conscience que la
valise et des groupes de médias comme
étant affiliés à des gouvernements est
un travail difficile
il y en a tellement c'est sympa les gars
bus ont réussi cette étiquette d'autres
médias d'état ne bénéficient toujours
pas de sept villages
voici donc quelques indices au plaisir
la bbc est le premier diffuseur public
au monde et à vie par une charte royale
la bbc est principalement financé par le
droit de licence payée par les ménages
britanniques ont aidé à remplir votre
mission est de promouvoir mon objectif
unique au québec est un radiodiffuseur
public financé par des ressources
fiscales fédérales mais diouf est
enregistrée auprès de narnia metz en
tant que société privée à but non
lucratif et est financé par une
subvention du congrès américain par
l'intermédiaire de l'agencé des états
unis pour les médias mondiaux en tant
que bénéficiaire
pourquoi une telle différence de
traitement les médias financés par les
institutions étatiques mais je me sens
d'une indépendance éditoriale ne sont
pas concernés ouais en gros vous fait la
pluie et le mouton et vous réserver le
droit de décider qui jouit d'une
indépendance éditoriale ou non mais
c'est quoi les critères en fait ce que
je vois pas le ca twitter ne le précise
pas il laisse le libre choix aux
internautes d'interpréter cette
différence de traitement comme une
discrimination politique c'est de la
pure discrimination c'est vous qui voyez
ce week-end le recommandera pas les
quantités médiatique la filière l'état
miller ce week-end à les appliquer là
bas nous avons demandé à l'avocat du
diable de arte va on lui a demandé ce
qu'il en pense quoi
c'est totalement discriminatoire et
illustre à merveille le parti pris des
réseaux sociaux américains
ces réseaux sociaux sont partis en
guerre idéologique contre ce qu'ils
considèrent comme étant le camp du mal
il leur sera désormais impossible de
continuer à revendiquer leur statut de
plateforme neutre
ils devront être traités comme des
éditeurs de contenus leur argument pour
qualifier les médias indépendants de
ceux qui ne le sont pas sont grotesques
pour quiconque s'intéresse un tant soit
peu aux médias en même temps j'ai envie
de dire la décision de twitter n'a rien
de surprenant vu les discriminations que
rt subit déjà en mai de l'année dernière
et youtube avait décidé de labelliser
les médias publics aux gouvernementaux
sous leurs vidéos mais avec une
différence sémantique notable rt
français selon la belle de youtube
financé par le gouvernement russe qu'en
france 24 où la bbc sont des chaînes de
service public français et ou
britanniques
deux poids deux mesures et bien sûr le
fait que werth et françois une chaîne
française composée de journalistes
français qui a signé une convention avec
le csa qui dispose d'une charte de
déontologie
deux syndicats de journalistes et d'un
comité d'éthique sa twitter s'en fout on
vit une époque formidable